So, Rob, I know
you've always wondered
why I didn't kiss you that day.
So tonight,
I will tell you why...in song.
[ Cheers and applause,
soft guitar music plays ]
♪ Rob was so shocked
on "The Lyon's Den" ♪
♪ When I did not want
to kiss him ♪
♪ You see the problem, Rob, is
you're such a whore ♪
♪ You completely forgot ♪
♪ We hooked up before ♪
♪ 'Cause you showed me ♪
♪ Your penis ♪
♪ When I was just 16-ish ♪
♪ Back in 1988 ♪
♪ I was that girl
on your sex tape ♪
♪ Maybe you missed my name ♪
♪ 'Cause you were high
on so much cocaine ♪
♪ Out of all your films ♪
♪ I'm the best thing
you were ever in ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Yeah, in his whole career ♪
♪ I'm the best thing
Rob Lowe has ever been in ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
And that's why I didn't want
to kiss you, you son of a bitch!
[ Song ends ]
Thank you.